God why is it so hard to find an
apartment I mean that place was a closet
I just when the listing said the
apartment was cozy
you should've included that the bathroom
was in the kitchen so what do you think
about that place back there I mean yeah
the building's super nice but it looks
expensive hi babe
what's your Wi-Fi password I'm gonna
look up some more places cheesy for 12
her first kiss
wait cheesy did you find my apartment
yet so there's this apartment within our
price range and I mean our as in maybe
we should move in together just because
I know you're having a hard time finding
a place and we basically live together
anyways do not I don't know it was just
an idea okay um maybe well I know I mean
what it would mean no more crosstown
commutes to see each other yeah and then
I'm home
hey welcome home you're not gonna scare
me off with some face cream all right
but you've never lived with a woman
before a lady has your secrets I
probably do some things that might be a
little annoying - but no secret oh now
you gotta tell me I've gotten a lot
better at leaving the toilet seat up and
I just I meant I'm down you know what
this could this could be really nice
you really think that yeah well it's
your lucky day that place back there is
within our price range do you know I've
never had a place to decorate exactly
the way I want like exactly
okay we're here oh yeah okay we can
decorate together together yeah you
almost had me with that oh come on what
are we gonna paint the bedroom pink no
cerulean I don't even know what that is
lavender no dusty lavender I don't
lavenders too girly